the term ideology has been pretty badly
abused one taken ideology is this
liberal conservative spectrum which is
purely destructive these days there's
ideology implicit in American values
again the Constitution the Declaration
of Independence and I pretty much go
with that along with the notion again
that you want to treat me like treat
people like you want to be treated you
want to get stuff done you want to
figure out what works you want to
alleviate suffering when you can that's
a kind of ideology I have fully bought
into that that seems to be the ideology
if you want to call that of the new
administration the idea is to forget to
some extent about political parties to
get done what people need in this
country to be to be done and I'm on
board
and I'm not an act
I'm just a guy from my point of view
who's standing up for other people this
is a new and exciting time and remember
I do customer service at craigslist for
a living and I've been doing that for
almost 14 years now and that's kind of
routine but now then i have this time
machine fantasy what would life be if i
was around during the war for
independence maybe world war two maybe
the be Tara right now we're in the
middle of an era kind of like all that
and more the course of human history is
changing right now and we're all part of
that to the extent we want to be and I
guess I'm playing a 0 a microscopic role
but it's something